Je m’appelle Jerry Dealey.
Je vis à Dallas où je suis né.
J’organise des visites guidées
qu’on appelle « JFK assassination tours ».
Pour moi, JFK est le premier président
dont je me souviens.
Mon nom est Kaplan Andrew.
J’étudie en finances ici au Texas.
Pour moi, JFK incarne l’importance
du charisme et de la personnalité en politique.
Mon nom est Bruno.
Je viens d’Allemagne.
Cet endroit est très important pour les
Allemands parce que
Kennedy est très connu chez nous.
Il a prononcé un discours en allemand
au mur de Berlin et il a dit :
« Je suis berlinois ».
C’était très important pour nous.
Je suis Ashley Park.
Je viens du Texas.
J’étudie en comptabilité.
JFK reste encore une énigme pour moi.
Et j’espère que ma génération
pourra enfin résoudre le mystère
qui a touché tant de monde.